in a recent technical interview i was
asked to debug the redux effect for the
lunar wayne shaft on a turbo
encapsulator but i failed because my
asynchronous anonymous function
abstraction was not item potent or
ephemeral and failed to memorize the
predicate and serialize the output
it's one thing if your code doesn't work
but it's impossible to fix if you don't
understand the words that describe the
problem
when you learn the code you not only
have to learn a programming language but
also a bunch of fancy words
that you would never use in a normal
conversation in today's video
we'll unpack and define a variety of
different technical words that you'll
definitely need to know for interviews
and your day-to-day work as a programmer
but first a quick word from our sponsor
work has been proceeding on the crudely
conceived idea of an instrument that
would not only provide
inverse reactive current for use in
unilateral phase detractors
but would also be capable of
automatically synchronizing cardinal
gram meters
rockwell automation's retro encapsulator
it's available soon
wherever rockwell automation products
are sold
item potent item potent the key part of
this word
is item which is latin for same the word
was coined in the 1800s in the context
of mathematics and it means an operation
that when applied multiple times will
always produce the same result for
example
multiplying by one multiple times always
produces the same result
that's an item potent operation unlike
multiplying by two which always produces
a different result
think of a crosswalk button if you push
it multiple times does it go any faster
no that's because it's an item potent
system in programming it means the same
thing
an operation or function that can be
called multiple times creating the same
output or side effect
for example if we have an array and we
push a new element to that array it's
making the array longer even if it's the
same element
so that is not item potent if we use a
set on the other hand
we can run the same operation multiple
times and it only keeps the unique
element
therefore adding an item to a set is
item potent this term comes to play most
often
in the context of apis the http verbs of
git
put and delete should always be
implemented in an item-potent way
in addition if you have an e-commerce
app where a user can submit a payment
you likely want that operation to be
item potent as well because posting the
same form
shouldn't result in multiple charges to
that customer ephemeral
ephemeral it comes from the greek word
ephemeros which means lasting only a day
think of an ephemeral plant like a
daylily whose flowers only last for a
day
in programming it's an antonym for terms
like persistent and immutable
at the hardware level your ram is
ephemeral while the hard disk is
persistent
when you shut down your computer any
memory in the ram is lost
while the data in the hard disk can be
retrieved later the term is also used to
define data structures within our code
for example
a plain javascript object is considered
ephemeral that's because we can mutate
its properties and have no way to get
back to the original object
however we can make it persistent or
immutable there's a bonus word for you
by calling object freeze which will
prevent any future modifications to the
object
but the place you might hear ephemeral
used most often is within the context of
cloud computing
many things in the cloud are becoming
serverless instead of a persistent
server always running in the cloud
we can use ephemeral servers
anonymous first and foremost the word is
used to describe a global group of
hacktivists that fight against things
like censorship and big government i
would highly recommend that you sign up
and put that on your resume today
but the word anonymous is also used in
our code primarily to define functions
that don't have a name take for example
a javascript function
or a python function if you prefer that
takes an argument and multiplies it by
two
what we have here is a named function
but it becomes cumbersome to pass name
functions around everywhere
especially as your code grows in
complexity and that's where anonymous
functions come in they're just functions
that don't have a name instead the
function is defined as the argument
therefore it doesn't need to be
referenced by a name in javascript we
can use an anonymous function with the
arrow syntax
but many other languages like python use
the lambda keyword to define an
anonymous function
the syntax feels a little weird at first
but is incredibly useful for small
simple functions as
arguments now speaking of functions that
brings us to our next fancy word
predicate the word has its roots in
latin for something declared or
proclaimed
in programming it most often means a
function that returns a single boolean
value
true or false by convention you'll often
see these functions start with the word
is is the value a turkey it's a simple
yes or no question
so we can return a boolean you might see
the word predicate come up more often
and strongly type languages like
typescript one cool thing we can do is
set up type
guards take for example this code where
we have an interface of a dog that can
bark
and a cat that can meow then we have a
function called make sound
that can take either a cat or a dog a
union type
as its argument the problem with this
code is that we don't know whether we
have a cat or a dog in the function body
however we can overcome this limitation
by setting up a predicate function
that checks whether or not the animal is
a cat if we then use the predicate or
type guard in our function body
typescript is smart enough to infer the
types based on this condition
if it's a cat we meow otherwise it has
to be a dog in which case we bark
memoization memoization i'm not sure if
this word means memo like a written
message
or memo like memory and although it
sounds like a scary word
it just means to cache the return value
of a function if you've ever used
react you might be familiar with the use
memo hook it creates a memoized value
by only re-running the function when its
dependencies change
the classic example is the fibonacci
sequence here we have a recursive
function
this function works but it needs to
recompute the same values over and over
again
we can optimize it by creating an empty
object and then when our function runs a
computation
it will save the value in this object
that means when we encounter the same
value again
we can use the value in memory instead
of recomputing it multiple times
when you hear the word memoization just
think memorization
of a return value from a function
abstraction
abstraction this word is derived from
the latin abs which means from
here which means draw so it roughly
translates to drawn from
in the most general sense it's the
process of hiding implementation details
from the end user
programming is like an onion it's layer
upon layer of abstractions
when you build an application you're
doing it on top of programming languages
and apis
that sit on top of networks and hardware
that sit on top of transistors and
electricity and so on
as a programmer you've likely heard the
phrase do not repeat yourself or
write dry code in this example we have a
shark and a tuna and both classes have
the same implementation details for
their swim method
rather than duplicate this code for each
class definition we can create an
abstract class called phish
the abstract keyword means this class
will never be instantiated on its own
because there is no such thing as a
generic fish
instead it's used to hide implementation
details that can be inherited from other
classes
which we can do by extending them with
the abstract class
and that's just one of many ways you can
create an abstraction in your code
the word itself really just means to
hide unnecessary implementation details
serialization serialization
this word comes from the english word
series which is just a collection of
items in a fixed order
in the programming world there's all
kinds of different languages and formats
and we often need to interop between
these different tools
java doesn't know how to understand php
code but what we can do
is take code from either language and
serialize it into a format that they
both understand
like binary then it can be deserialized
back into code that can be used natively
take for example a javascript app and a
python app that communicate over an api
we have a javascript object that we want
to use in our python app as a dictionary
before we send the object from
javascript we serialize it as a string
json is a standard format that can be
understood by virtually all modern
languages
that's how we serialize a javascript
object then we can go back into our
python code
and deserialize it by using json loads
the bottom line here is that
serialization is the process
of taking data from one format and
converting it to a more generic form
that can be used by other programs i'm
going to go ahead and wrap things up
there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one the
lineup consisted simply of six
hydrocoptic marshall veins
so fitted to the ambifacent lunar wane
shaft that side fumbling was
effectively prevented